damit kommt meine lieben freunde wisst
ja dass mir auf achterbahn immer sehr
schnell sehr schlecht wird von daher
spielen wir heute app wie groß das in
virtual reality losgeht okay leute wir
befinden uns jetzt hier in virtual
reality zum staaten den gurt festhalten
und ziehen
ich habe kein gutes
ich bin mega gespannt hier fliegen die
vögel rum da hinten ist eine wolke echt
der absolute wahnsinn
da vorne ist ein kleiner strand mw wird
es mich verarschen als ich fahr nach
hinten ach du heilige scheiße ich musste
mein mikro festhalten ich weiß nicht wo
oben und unten ist der kommt hoch wie
das für schlechte animierte steine also
so sieht es aus wenn die nach hinten
gucken wir sind da ganz hinten muss ich
da gleich auch noch durch ja damals erst
mal wieder davor
wollt ihr mich verarschen mir ist jetzt
schon gott verdammt schlecht ich weiß
nicht ob ich weiß nicht ob das zuhause
bei euch vom handy oder vorm computer
richtig rüberkommt dass es nicht wahr
das ist jetzt nicht dein ernst oder
meinrad leute also helfe ich komm nicht
klar wo wir nichts weiter übrig als am
helllichten tag
ich komm nicht klar alte schwede ich
weiß nicht ob es bei euch zu hause so
rüberkommen wie bei mir hier gerade ist
aber ich bin so wackelig auf den beinen
das ding ist ja auch immer meine wieder
zum spielen auf nicht im sitzen
auch hier ist das mikro ist gar nicht so
dass wir da vorne schon hoch genug war
ein mal das boden gucken luca ruch der
boden
das ist nicht wahr
das kann doch nicht sein dass mich so
ein virtual reality spielt so aus der
fassung bringt ich weiß nicht ob man sie
doch man sieht wahrscheinlich gerade
absolut gar nix ich bin komplett am
schwitzen ich will hier fehlt eine
strecke super
klasse das ist nicht so schlimm das
war's wie gehts super ich würde sagen
wir fahren direkt noch eine strecke
wollt ihr mich verarschen
ich habe schiss das ist dinosaurier ist
ja ich sehe schon wieder die steine
kommen ein wahnsinn
die sind gar nicht mal so schlecht
animiert ehrlich gesagt jetzt ehrlich
gesagt immer noch ein bisschen schlecht
von der ersten runde die wir vorhin
gefahren sind
da macht es das jetzt besser mal schauen
wie es jetzt weitergeht einem akku
kinder sind diese kleinen teile der
springt hier so komisch rüber alter das
sagen eine ganz komische bewegung
da hätten ja die gal auf den gleisen
herum touren wir werden auf jeden fall
immer schnell
okay okay wir sind wieder auf der bahn
wir sind mega schnell gerade unterwegs
ist tut mir leid falls der tunnel bilden
looping raus gebe ihm bruder
das ist ein arschloch na ja hallo auch
an dich ein wahnsinn hier vorne aber
nicht wunderschönen tag
du siehst müssen versteinert aus ein
paar sekunden später wollte ich jetzt
gerade nicht so gut
[Musik]
ach so verfolgte mich jetzt oder was
ich kann nicht mehr ich glaube dass das
steckt man nicht wenn man irgendwie vom
handy sitzen sich das anguckt oder so
aber ich bin ich bin tot
an der stelle würde ich somit das
heutige wie die jetzt auch werden meine
lieben freunde hatten mich komplett
fertiggemacht mal wieder was mit dieser
oculus aufzunehmen das haben sich so
viele von euch gewünscht unter meinem
letzten video wo ich damit minecraft
gezockt hab vor 12 monaten ebenfalls ihr
wollt dass ich damit noch mal was spiele
schreibt mir und in die kommentare last
einen daumen hoch bei dem video da und
abonniert über einen kanal keine videos
halten mehr verpassen wollte kostenlos
und ich jetzt glaube ich kotzen
[Musik]